wedding bells are ringing for mr. and
mrs. the rock yes that's right Dwayne
the rock Johnson tied the knot with his
longtime love Lauren hash Ian the 47
year old took to Instagram to share the
happy news posting these stunning pics
with his gorgeous bride he captioned the
shots quote we do adding their wedding
date and location August 18th
Hawaii and the Hawaiian phrase for the
last cute for his big day the actor wore
white pants and a semi sheer white shirt
and embraced Hawaiian tradition by
rocking two draped lays his 34 year old
bride looked Gorge in a white lace
covered gown with a long veil there's
nothing better the lovebirds share two
daughters three-year-old Jasmine and
one-year-old TIA
Lauren does a tremendous job I'm really
so proud of her she is just a super mom
I tell her all the time I'm like you're
my superwoman baby the rock is also dad
to eighteen-year-old Simone whom he
shares with his ex-wife Danny Garcia the
daddy-daughter relationship is you see
I'm always gonna be daddy like in my
mind right yeah so it's very very cool
very very proud of her the best piece of
advice that my dad gave me was just to
have fun and live in the moment and I'm
keeping that in the back of my mind with
everything I do in this journey Danny
and the a-lister were married from 1997
to 2007 and still remain good friends
that's great
and it's okay that he's like doesn't
have any men in the house yes
yeah and Wald's Wayne and Lauren just
made their love official he told UT and
2018 that he was already calling her his
wife I refer to as my wife all the time
that's a lot of people are like rush Big
Daddy and earlier that year he revealed
that they were already supposed to have
exchanged vows but life changed their
plans for them we were going to get
married in the spring and then we got
pregnant and Lauren felt like well you
know what I don't know if mama wants to
take pictures you know in being pregnant
in wedding dress so we're just gonna
wait and I'm not going to sure when but
I know it's gonna happen these two are
seriously so cute and I love a good
happily ever after this is a good way to
start the week of course we'll be here
to keep you up-to-date on all the things
the rock has lined up so make sure to
keep it locked right here on ET until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now